first the topping he olive oil in a  frying pan  had ten cannellini beans along with the  juices  once heated gently mash the beans with a  fork  then add sliced black olives roughly  chopped parsley and a splash of sherry  vinegar  season and leave on a gentle heat  next hi professor batter and splash with  extra virgin olive oil  he's a griddle pan until smoking and  toast the bread all side down pressing  it into the pan to chart evenly to serve  top the toasted ciabatta with a khalili  bean mixture and finish with chopped  anchovies  packed with bold flavors so easy you can  always make it blindfolded ready in  under 10 minutes but eaten in seconds  thinly sliced fresh fennel and scatter  over the toasted flatbread  then toast aromatic fennel seeds in a  hot dry pan next drain your pasta and  combined with a sardine chilli and  garlic mixture add leaves of fresh  oregano